on a quelqu'un qui veut nous faire une
petite surprise cl voilà qui était aussi
au début de tpm p je me rappelle aussi
je pense qu'on va en parler de son
recrutement parce que c'était une énorme
d'arc a aussi ses et nos raquettes avec
nous comment ça va shihri savarino est
pourquoi qu'elle n' aura elles ont l'air
plus en forme que les vôtres quelques
jambes et est celle où kelly et n'aura
cédé deux seuls qui sont fraîches sur la
tête de la verrière d'exemple à tout et
est donc normal non mais sans rigoler
c'est bien peu choquerait tu vois c'est
quand même les dix ans ça va mon hainaut
ouais ça va écoute moi je sais que vous
fait on est sur une prise de kilos en
tutelle et fais-toi plaisir et un drap
le bilan on fera le bilan après le
confinement on s'en fout enoh qui fait
toujours partie de la famille je dois
dire parce qu'elle avec eric dans de
quoi je me mêle
et c'est la famille à eric naulleau bien
entendu et mon hainaut est ce que tu te
rappelles hainaut de te recrutement
commente avaient été recrutés dans tpm
pétoires avait acheté payer non j'y
donnais de l'oseille dont je crois un
tas de des données non moi je me
rappelle je t'avais vu dans une émission
ouais et et j'avais dit j'avais appelé
je me rappelle la produit le producteur
de l'émission j'avais dit il nourrir
faut absolument c'est elle qui nous
manque dont l'émission est purement
halal et u10 je ressemblais à kurt
cobain vraiment mais c'était magnifique
h tu ne mettais plein des vestes
militaires
cathy crowe tu te souviens mais je m'en
rappelle elle mettait la veste kaki
toute la journée alors qu'ils étaient en
j'avais connu un stade car il est
pratiquement au début maintenant d'un
personnage historique de l'émission
et c'est vrai que enora très vite elle
était connue pour ses coups de coeur
voilà c'est qu'elle elle disait ce
qu'elle pense et c'est vrai coup de
coeur et coups de gueule ce concours
télé mais aussi ça pollue le disais en
voilà et c'est pour ça et c'est pour ça
que tu es devenu un personnage
historique de l'émission regardez dos on
à la première émission dans tpm pergola
non allez c'est terminé ton grand talent
je sors puisque toi
rien n'est plus en vigueur 2000 moi j'ai
une émission de radio tous les soirs en
trouvant des terminaux jeunes qui se met
c'est drôle moi ça ne me fait peur je
suis comme guy ce n'est pas divertissant
si demain je vais avoir le boulard je
n'ai pas eu à 20 ans je l'aurais pas 41
ans et si effectivement j'avais le
boulard je pense que je ferai des doigts
d'honneur il serait pas spectateur et
j'en suis très des handicapés est
d'ailleurs j'aimerais te dire une chose
vraiment non mais ne fait pas les
étonnés
oui ces parcours décor l'asie mon écoute
mon enfant voulant vouloir vous les
messieurs arrêtez de dire que j'en veux
je vous en sentez vous dans la vie c'est
comme comme malagré où est ce qu'on va
faire c'est pas gentil c'est chaud là et
j'espère ne soit pas soit pas méprisant
comme si chaud que ça ne va vu la
séquence je parle de tostan sens pendant
trois semaines bon et ils ont fait le
consul vite fait notre mea et nous
remercions tous cas d'être là ils n'ont
pas trouvé ta première puce et la régie
on les aime mais c'est vrai que les
équipes n'ont pas changé en plus ça
travaille de chez elle maintenant donc
il est une personne face à un ordinateur
donc on les embrasse comme elle ils font
le maximum à maui et bien on va chez lui
et nous je voulais dire est ce que toi
tu as un souvenir de tpm pis j'en ai
plein j'en ai plein moi je dois en
partage et deux avec toi un collectif et
un perso le collectif rapidement ses
quais se cache cache géant
on avait fait un tabac organisé gad
elmaleh qui tout bien et qu'elle alors
je me suis dit mais quelle émission de
télé alors que normalement un
cache-cache c'est un truc entre soit tu
vois voilà quelle émission capable de
défoncer un conducteur est d'organiser
un cache-cache est en effet celui avec
tous les copains je me souviens de
jean-mi étiquetté en premier degré on se
cache évidemment
donc c'était un os à la fonte des
souvenirs où je sais que tout le monde
en a parlé après pendant des années
tellement c'est un moment de télé
deuxième personnellement c'est que grâce
à toi j'ai quand même sauté dans le vide
en un saut à l'élastique de malades et
ça et ça je suis désolé encore une fois
quelle émission de télé le pervers avec
toutes les conditions de sécurité
évidemment autour et avec les copains
derrière qui m'encourageait toi qui
étais hyper sympa et à taper des trucs
de ouf un bien peu mais comme nous tous
on a fait des trucs que dans l'évolution
de
ils sont télé et ça c'est génial c'est
d'ailleurs journaliste et non écoulables
parler de ça parce que je vais leur
annoncer une grande nouvelle
sachez que l'année prochaine tous les
soirs il y aura un très gros happening
donc voilà je serai des tracts utilisent
j'espère qu'il va pas m'appeler l'année
prochaine mon éloge ce fait le gros
bisous match et d'avoir été là et vient
et bien devoir vite matière et on
t'embrasse fort alors simon elo baba